So, the topic today is dynamic
programming.
The term programming in the
name of this term doesn't refer
to computer programming.
OK, programming is an old word
that means any tabular method
for accomplishing something.
So, you'll hear about linear
programming and dynamic
programming.
Either of those,
even though we now incorporate
those algorithms in computer
programs, originally computer
programming, you were given a
datasheet and you put one line
per line of code as a tabular
method for giving the machine
instructions as to what to do.
OK, so the term programming is
older.
Of course, and now
conventionally when you see
programming, you mean software,
computer programming.
But that wasn't always the
case.
And these terms continue in the
literature.
So, dynamic programming is a
design technique like other
design techniques we've seen
such as divided and conquer.
OK, so it's a way of solving a
class of problems rather than a
particular algorithm or
something.
So, we're going to work through
this for the example of
so-called longest common
subsequence problem,
sometimes called LCS,
OK, which is a problem that
comes up in a variety of
contexts.
And it's particularly important
in computational biology,
where you have long DNA
strains, and you're trying to
find commonalities between two
strings, OK, one which may be a
genome, and one may be various,
when people do,
what is that thing called when
they do the evolutionary
comparisons?
The evolutionary trees,
yeah, right,
yeah, exactly,
phylogenetic trees,
there you go,
OK, phylogenetic trees.
Good, so here's the problem.
So, you're given two sequences,
x going from one to m,
and y running from one to n.
You want to find a longest
sequence common to both.
OK, and here I say a,
not the, although it's common
to talk about the longest common
subsequence.
Usually the longest comment
subsequence isn't unique.
There could be several
different subsequences that tie
for that.
However, people tend to,
it's one of the sloppinesses
that people will say.
I will try to say a,
unless it's unique.
But I may slip as well because
it's just such a common thing to
just talk about the,
even though there might be
multiple.
So, here's an example.
Suppose x is this sequence,
and y is this sequence.
So, what is a longest common
subsequence of those two
sequences?
See if you can just eyeball it.
AB: length two?
Anybody have one longer?
Excuse me?
BDB, BDB.
BDAB, BDAB, BDAB,
anything longer?
So, BDAB: that's the longest
one.
Is there another one that's the
same length?
Is there another one that ties?
BCAB, BCAB, another one?
BCBA, yeah, there are a bunch
of them all of length four.
There isn't one of length five.
OK, we are actually going to
come up with an algorithm that,
if it's correct,
we're going to show it's
correct, guarantees that there
isn't one of length five.
So all those are,
we can say, any one of these is
the longest comment subsequence
of x and y.
We tend to use it this way
using functional notation,
but it's not a function that's
really a relation.
So, we'll say something is an
LCS when really we only mean
it's an element,
if you will,
of the set of longest common
subsequences.
Once again, it's classic
abusive notation.
As long as we know what we
mean, it's OK to abuse notation.
What we can't do is misuse it.
But abuse, yeah!
Make it so it's easy to deal
with.
But you have to know what's
going on underneath.
OK, so let's see,
so there's a fairly simple
brute force algorithm for
solving this problem.
And that is,
let's just check every,
maybe some of you did this in
your heads, subsequence of x
from one to m to see if it's
also a subsequence of y of one
to n.
So, just take every subsequence
that you can get here,
check it to see if it's in
there.
So let's analyze that.
So, to check,
so if I give you a subsequence
of x, how long does it take you
to check whether it is,
in fact, a subsequence of y?
So, I give you something like
BCAB.
How long does it take me to
check to see if it's a
subsequence of y?
Length of y,
which is order n.
And how do you do it?
Yeah, you just scan.
So as you hit the first
character that matches,
great.
Now, if you will,
recursively see whether the
suffix of your string matches
the suffix of x.
OK, and so, you are just simply
walking down the tree to see if
it matches.
You're walking down the string
to see if it matches.
OK, then the second thing is,
then how many subsequences of x
are there?
Two to the n?
x just goes from one to m,
two to the m subsequences of x,
OK, two to the m.
Two to the m subsequences of x,
OK, one way to see that,
you say, well,
how many subsequences are there
of something there?
If I consider a bit vector of
length m, OK,
that's one or zero,
just every position where
there's a one,
I take out, that identifies an
element that I'm going to take
out.
OK, then that gives me a
mapping from each subsequence of
x, from each bit vector to a
different subsequence of x.
Now, of course,
you could have matching
characters there,
that in the worst case,
all of the characters are
different.
OK, and so every one of those
will be a unique subsequence.
So, each bit vector of length m
corresponds to a subsequence.
That's a generally good trick
to know.
So, the worst-case running time
of this method is order n times
two to the m,
which is, since m is in the
exponent, is exponential time.
And there's a technical term
that we use when something is
exponential time.
Slow: good.
OK, very good.
OK, slow, OK,
so this is really bad.
This is taking a long time to
crank out how long the longest
common subsequence is because
there's so many subsequences.
OK, so we're going to now go
through a process of developing
a far more efficient algorithm
for this problem.
OK, and we're actually going to
go through several stages.
The first one is to go through
simplification stage.
OK, and what we're going to do
is look at simply the length of
the longest common sequence of x
and y.
And then what we'll do is
extend the algorithm to find the
longest common subsequence
itself.
OK, so we're going to look at
the length.
So, simplify the problem,
if you will,
to just try to compute the
length.
What's nice is the length is
unique.
OK, there's only going to be
one length that's going to be
the longest.
OK, and what we'll do is just
focus on the problem of
computing the length.
And then we'll do is we can
back up from that and figure out
what actually is the subsequence
that realizes that length.
OK, and that will be a big
simplification because we don't
have to keep track of a lot of
different possibilities at every
stage.
We just have to keep track of
the one number,
which is the length.
So, it's sort of reduces it to
a numerical problem.
We'll adopt the following
notation.
It's pretty standard notation,
but I just want,
if I put absolute values around
the string or a sequence,
it denotes the length of the
sequence, S.
OK, so that's the first thing.
The second thing we're going to
do is, actually,
we're going to,
which takes a lot more insight
when you come up with a problem
like this,
and in some sense,
ends up being the hardest part
of designing a good dynamic
programming algorithm from any
problem, which is we're going to
actually look not at all
subsequences of x and y,
but just prefixes.
OK, we're just going to look at
prefixes and we're going to show
how we can express the length of
the longest common subsequence
of prefixes in terms of each
other.
In particular,
we're going to define c of ij
to be the length,
the longest common subsequence
of the prefix of x going from
one to i, and y of going to one
to j.
And what we are going to do is
we're going to calculate c[i,j]
for all ij.
And if we do that,
how then do we solve the
problem of the longest common of
sequence of x and y?
How do we solve the longest
common subsequence?
Suppose we've solved this for
all I and j.
How then do we compute the
length of the longest common
subsequence of x and y?
Yeah, c[m,n],
that's all, OK?
So then, c of m,
n is just equal to the longest
common subsequence of x and y,
because if I go from one to n,
I'm done, OK?
And so, it's going to turn out
that what we want to do is
figure out how to express to
c[m,n], in general,
c[i,j], in terms of other
c[i,j].
So, let's see how we do that.
OK, so our theorem is going to
say that c[i,j] is just --
OK, it says that if the i'th
character matches the j'th
character, then i'th character
of x matches the j'th character
of y, then c of ij is just c of
I minus one, j minus one plus
one.
And if they don't match,
then it's either going to be
the longer of c[i,
j-1], and c[i-1,
j], OK?
So that's what we're going to
prove.
And that's going to give us a
way of relating the calculation
of a given c[i,j] to values that
are strictly smaller,
OK, that is at least one of the
arguments is smaller of the two
arguments.
OK, and that's going to give us
a way of being able,
then, to understand how to
calculate c[i,j].
So, let's prove this theorem.
So, we'll start with a case
x[i] equals y of j.
And so, let's draw a picture
here.
So, we have x here.
And here is y.
OK, so here's my sequence,
x, which I'm sort of drawing as
this elongated box,
sequence y, and I'm saying that
x[i] and y[j],
those are equal.
OK, so let's see what that
means.
OK, so let's let z of one to k
be, in fact, the longest common
subsequence of x of one to i,
y of one to j,
where c of ij is equal to k.
OK, so the longest common
subsequence of x and y of one to
I and y of one to j has some
value.
Let's call it k.
And so, let's say that we have
some sequence which realizes
that.
OK, we'll call it z.
OK, so then,
can somebody tell me what z of
k is?
What is z of k here?
Yeah, it's actually equal to x
of I, which is also equal to y
of j?
Why is that?
Why couldn't it be some other
value?
Yeah, so you got the right
idea.
So, the idea is,
suppose that the sequence
didn't include this element here
at the last element,
the longest common subsequence.
OK, so then it includes a bunch
of values in here,
and a bunch of values in here,
same values.
It doesn't include this or
this.
Well, then I could just tack on
this extra character and make it
be longer, make it k plus one
because these two match.
OK, so if the sequence ended
before --
-- just extend it by tacking on
x[i].
OK, it would be fairly simple
to just tack on x[i].
OK, so if that's the case,
then if I look at z going one
up to k minus one,
that's certainly a common
sequence of x of 1 up to,
excuse me, of up to i minus
one.
And, y of one up to j minus
one, OK, because this is a
longest common sequence.
z is a longest common sequence
is, from x of one to i,
y of one to j.
And, we know what the last
character is.
It's just x[i],
or equivalently,
y[j].
So therefore,
everything except the last
character must at least be a
common sequence of x of one to i
minus one, y of one to j minus
one.
Everybody with me?
It must be a comment sequence.
OK, now, what you also suspect?
What do you also suspect about
z of one to k?
It's a common sequence of these
two.
Yeah?
Yeah, it's a longest common
sequence.
So that's what we claim,
z of one up to k minus one is
in fact a longest common
subsequence of x of one to i
minus one, and y of one to j
minus one, OK?
So, let's prove that claim.
So, we'll just have a little
diversion to prove the claim.
OK, so suppose that w is a
longer comment sequence,
that is, that the length,
the w, is bigger than k minus
one.
OK, so suppose we have a longer
comment sequence than z of one
to k minus one.
So, it's got to have length
that's bigger than k minus one
if it's longer.
OK, and now what we do is we
use a classic argument you're
going to see multiple times,
not just this week,
which it will be important for
this week, but through several
lectures.
Hence, it's called a cut and
paste argument.
So, the idea is let's take a
look at w, concatenate it with
that last character,
z of k.
so, this is string,
OK, so that's just my
terminology for string
concatenation.
OK, so I take whatever I
claimed was a longer comment
subsequence, and I concatenate z
of k to it.
OK, so that is certainly a
common sequence of x of one to I
minus one, and y of one to j.
And it has length bigger than k
because it's basically,
what is its length?
The length of w is bigger than
k minus one.
I add one character.
So, this combination here,
now, has length bigger that k.
OK, and that's a contradiction,
thereby proving the claim.
So, I'm simply saying,
I claim this.
Suppose you have a longer one.
Well, let me show,
if I had a longer common
sequence for the prefixes where
we dropped the character from
both strings if it was longer
there, but we would have made
the whole thing longer.
So that can't be.
So, therefore,
this must be a longest common
subsequence, OK?
Questions?
Because you are going to need
to be able to do this kind of
proof ad nauseam,
almost.
So, if there any questions,
let them at me,
people.
OK, so now what we have
established is that z one
through k is a longest common
subsequence of the two prefixes
when we drop the last character.
So, thus, we have c of i minus
one, j minus one is equal to
what?
What's c of i minus one,
j minus one?
k minus one;
thank you.
Let's move on with the class,
right, OK, which implies that c
of ij is just equal to c of I
minus one, j minus one plus one.
So, it's fairly straightforward
if you think about what's going
on there.
It's not always as
straightforward in some problems
as it is for longest common
subsequence.
The idea is,
so I'm not going to go through
the other cases.
They are similar.
But, in fact,
we've hit on one of the two
hallmarks of dynamic
programming.
So, by hallmarks,
I mean when you see this kind
of structure in a problem,
there's a good chance that
dynamic programming is going to
work as a strategy.
The dynamic programming
hallmark is the following.
This is number one.
And that is the property of
optimal substructure.
OK, what that says is an
optimal solution to a problem,
and by this,
we really mean problem
instance.
But it's tedious to keep saying
problem instance.
A problem is generally,
in computer science,
viewed as having an infinite
number of instances typically,
OK, so sorting is a problem.
A sorting instance is a
particular input.
OK, so we're really talking
about problem instances,
but I'm just going to say
problem, OK?
So, when you have an optimal
solution to a problem,
contains optimal solutions to
subproblems.
OK, and that's worth drawing a
box around because it's so
important.
OK, so here,
for example,
if z is a longest common
subsequence of x and y,
OK, then any prefix of z is a
longest common subsequence of a
prefix of x, and a prefix of y,
OK?
So, this is basically what it
says.
I look at the problem,
and I can see that there is
optimal substructure going on.
OK, in this case,
and the idea is that almost
always, it means that there's a
cut and paste argument you could
do to demonstrate that,
OK, that if the substructure
were not optimal,
then you'd be able to find a
better solution to the overall
problem using cut and paste.
OK, so this theorem,
now, gives us a strategy for
being able to compute longest
comment subsequence.
Here's the code; oh wait.
OK, so going to ignore base
cases in this,
if --
And we will return the value of
the longest common subsequence.
It's basically just
implementing this theorem.
OK, so it's either the longest
comment subsequence if they
match.
It's the longest comment
subsequence of one of the
prefixes where you drop that
character for both strengths and
add one because that's the
matching one.
Or, you drop a character from
x, and it's the longest comment
subsequence of that.
Or you drop a character from y,
whichever one of those is
longer.
That ends up being the longest
comment subsequence.
OK, so what's the worst case
for this program?
What's going to happen in the
worst case?
Which of these two clauses is
going to cause us more headache?
The second clause:
why the second clause?
Yeah, you're doing two LCS
sub-calculations here.
Here, you're only doing one.
Not only that,
but you get to decrement both
indices, whereas here you've
basically got to,
you only get to decrement one
index, and you've got to
calculate two of them.
So that's going to generate the
tree.
So, and the worst case,
x of i is not equal to x of j
for all i and j.
So, let's draw a recursion tree
for this program to sort of get
an understanding as to what is
going on to help us.
And, I'm going to do it with m
equals seven,
and n equals six.
OK, so we start up the top with
my two indices being seven and
six.
And then, in the worst case,
we had to execute these.
So, this is going to end up
being six, six,
and seven, five for indices
after the first call.
And then, this guy is going to
split.
And he's going to produce five,
six here, decrement the first
index, I.
And then, if I keep going down
here, we're going to get four,
six and five,
five.
And these guys keep extending
here.
I get six five,
five five, six four,
OK?
Over here, I'm going to get
decrement the first index,
six five, and I get five five,
six four, and these guys keep
going down.
And over here,
I get seven four.
And then we get six four,
seven three,
and those keep going down.
So, we keep just building this
tree out.
OK, so what's the height of
this tree?
Not of this one for the
particular value of m and n,
but in terms of m and n.
What's the height of this tree?
It's the max of m and n.
You've got the right,
it's theta of the max.
It's not the max.
Max would be,
in this case,
you're saying it has height
seven.
But, I think you can sort of
see, for example,
along a path like this that,
in fact, I've only,
after going three levels,
reduced m plus n,
good, very good,
m plus n.
So, height here is m plus n.
OK, and its binary.
So, the height:
that implies the work is
exponential in m and n.
All that work,
and are we any better off than
the brute force algorithm?
Not really.
And, our technical term for
this is slow.
OK, and we like speed.
OK, we like fast.
OK, but I'm sure that some of
you have observed something
interesting about this tree.
Yeah, there's a lot of repeated
work here.
Right, there's a lot of
repeated work.
In particular,
this whole subtree,
and this whole subtree,
OK, they are the same.
That's the same subtree,
the same subproblem that you
are solving.
OK, you can even see over here,
there is even similarity
between this whole subtree and
this whole subtree.
OK, so there's lots of repeated
work.
OK, and one thing is,
if you want to do things fast,
don't keep doing the same
thing.
OK, don't keep doing the same
When you find you are repeating
something, figure out a way of
not doing it.
So, that brings up our second
hallmark for dynamic
programming.
And that's a property called
overlapping subproblems,
OK?
OK, recursive solution contains
many, excuse me,
contains a small number of
distinct subproblems repeated
many times.
And once again,
this is important enough to put
a box around.
I don't put boxes around too
many things.
Maybe I should put our boxes
around things.
This is definitely one to put a
box around, OK?
So, for example,
so here we have a recursive
solution.
This tree is exponential in
size.
It's two to the m plus n in
height, in size,
in the total number of problems
if I actually implemented like
that.
But how many distinct
subproblems are there?
m times n, OK?
So, the longest comment
subsequence, the subproblem
space contains m times n,
distinct subproblems.
OK, and then this is a small
number compared with two to the
m plus n, or two to the n,
or two to the m,
or whatever.
OK, this is small,
OK, because for each
subproblem, it's characterized
by an I and a j.
An I goes from one to m,
and j goes from one to n,
OK?
There aren't that many
different subproblems.
It's just the product of the
two.
So, here's an improved
algorithm, which is often a good
way to solve it.
It's an algorithm called a
memo-ization algorithm.
And, this is memo-ization,
not memorization because what
you're going to do is make a
little memo whenever you solve a
subproblem.
Make a little memo that says I
solved this already.
And if ever you are asked for
it rather than recalculating it,
say, oh, I see that.
I did that before.
Here's the answer,
OK?
So, here's the code.
It's very similar to that code.
So, it basically keeps a table
around of c[i,j].
It says, what we do is we
check.
If the entry for c[i,j] is nil,
we haven't computed it,
then we compute it.
And, how do we compute it?
Just the same way we did
before.
OK, so this whole part here,
OK, is exactly what we have had
before.
It's the same as before.
And then, we just return
c[i,j].
If we don't bother to keep
recalculating,
OK, so if it's nil,
we calculate it.
Otherwise, we just return it.
It's not calculated,
calculate and return it.
Otherwise, just return it:
OK, pretty straightforward
code.
OK.
OK, now the tricky thing is how
much time does it take to
execute this?
This takes a little bit of
thinking.
Yeah?
Yeah, it takes order MN.
OK, why is that?
Yeah, but I have to look up
c[i,j].
I might call c[i,j] a bunch of
times.
When I'm doing this,
I'm still calling it
recursively.
Yeah, so you have to,
so each recursive call is going
to look at, and the worst-case,
say, is going to look at the
max of these two things.
Well, this is going to involve
a recursive call,
and a lookup.
So, this might take a fair
amount of effort to calculate.
I mean, you're right,
and your intuition is right.
Let's see if we can get a more
precise argument,
why this is taking order m
times n.
What's going on here?
Because not every time I call
this is it going to just take me
a constant amount of work to do
this.
Sometimes it's going to take me
a lot of work.
Sometimes I get lucky,
and I return it.
So, your intuition is dead on.
It's dead on.
We just need a little bit more
articulate explanation,
so that everybody is on board.
Try again?
Good, at most three times,
yeah.
OK, so that's one way to look
at it.
Yeah.
There is another way to look at
it that's kind of what you are
expressing there is an
amortized, a bookkeeping,
way of looking at this.
What's the amortized cost?
You could say what the
amortized cost of calculating
one of these,
where basically whenever I call
it, I'm going to charge a
constant amount for looking up.
And so, I could get to look up
whatever is in here to call the
things.
But if it, in fact,
so in some sense,
this charge here,
of calling it and returning it,
etc., I charged that to my
caller.
OK, so I charged these lines
and this line to the caller.
And I charge the rest of these
lines to the c[i,j] element.
And then, the point is that
every caller basically only ends
up being charged for a constant
amount of stuff.
OK, to calculate one c[i,j],
it's only an amortized constant
amount of stuff that I'm
charging to that calculation of
i and j, that calculation of i
and j.
OK, so you can view it in terms
of amortized analysis doing a
bookkeeping argument that just
says, let me charge enough to
calculate my own,
do all my own local things plus
enough to look up the value in
the next level and get it
returned.
OK, and then if it has to go
off and calculate,
well, that's OK because that's
all been charged to a different
ij at that point.
So, every cell only costs me a
constant amount of time that
order MN cells total of order
MN.
OK: constant work per entry.
OK, and you can sort of use an
amortized analysis to argue
that.
How much space does it take?
We haven't usually looked at
space, but here we are going to
start looking at space.
That turns out,
for some of these algorithms,
to be really important.
How much space do I need,
storage space?
Yeah, also m times n,
OK, to store the c[i,j] table.
OK, the rest,
storing x and y,
OK, that's just m plus n.
So, that's negligible,
but mostly I need the space m
times n.
So, this memo-ization type
algorithm is a really good
strategy in programming for many
things where,
when you have the same
parameters, you're going to get
the same results.
It doesn't work in programs
where you have a side effect,
necessarily,
that is, when the calculation
for a given set of parameters
might be different on each call.
But for something which is
essentially like a functional
programming type of environment,
then if you've calculated it
once, you can look it up.
And, so this is very helpful.
But, it takes a fair amount of
space, and it also doesn't
proceed in a very orderly way.
So, there is another strategy
for doing exactly the same
calculation in a bottom-up way.
And that's what we call dynamic
programming.
OK, the idea is to compute the
table bottom-up.
I think I'm going to get rid
of, I think what we'll do is
we'll just use,
actually I think what I'm going
to do is use this board.
OK, so here's the idea.
What we're going to do is look
at the c[i,j] table and realize
that there's actually an orderly
way of filling in the table.
This is sort of a top-down with
memo-ization.
OK, but there's actually a way
we can do it bottom up.
So, here's the idea.
So, let's make our table.
OK, so there's x.
And then, there's y.
And, I'm going to initialize
the empty string.
I didn't cover the base cases
for c[i,j], but c of zero
meaning a prefix with no
elements in it.
The prefix of that with
anything else,
the length is zero.
OK, so that's basically how I'm
going to bound the borders here.
And now, what I can do is just
use my formula,
which I've conveniently erased
up there, OK,
to compute what is the longest
common subsequence,
length of the longest comment
subsequence from this character
in y, and this character in x up
to this character.
So here, for example,
they don't match.
So, it's the maximum of these
two values.
Here, they do match.
OK, so it says it's one plus
the value here.
And, I'm going to draw a line.
Whenever I'm going to get a
match, I'm going to draw a line
like that, indicating that I had
that first case,
the case where they had a good
match.
And so, all I'm doing is
applying that recursive formula
from the theorem that we proved.
So here, it's basically they
don't match.
So, it's the maximum of those
two.
Here, they match.
So, it's one plus that guy.
Here, they don't match.
So, it's basically the maximum
of these two.
Here, they don't match.
So it's the maximum.
So, it's one plus that guy.
So, everybody understand how I
filled out that first row?
OK, well that you guys can
help.
OK, so this one is what?
Just call it out.
Zero, good.
One, because it's the maximum,
one, two, right.
This one, now,
gets from there,
two, two.
OK, here, zero,
one, because it's the maximum
of those two.
Two, two, two,
good.
One, one, two,
two, two, three,
three.
One, two, three,
get that line,
three, four,
OK.
One there, three,
three, four,
good, four.
OK, and our answer:
four.
So this is blindingly fast code
if you code this up,
OK, because it gets to use the
fact that modern machines in
particular do very well on
regular strides through memory.
So, if you're just plowing
through memory across like this,
OK, and your two-dimensional
array is stored in that order,
which it is,
otherwise you go this way,
stored in that order.
This can really fly in terms of
the speed of the calculation.
So, how much time did it take
us to do this?
Yeah, order MN,
theta MN.
Yeah?
We'll talk about space in just
a minute.
OK, so hold that question.
Good question,
good question,
already, wow,
good, OK, how do I now figure
out, remember,
we had the simplification.
We were going to just calculate
the length.
OK, it turns out I can now
figure out a particular sequence
that matches it.
And basically,
I do that.
I can reconstruct the longest
common subsequence by tracing
backwards.
So essentially I start here.
Here I have a choice because
this one was dependent on,
since it doesn't have a bar
here, it was dependent on one of
these two.
So, let me go this way.
OK, and now I have a diagonal
element here.
So what I'll do is simply mark
the character that appeared in
those positions as I go this
way.
I have three here.
And now, let me keep going,
three here, and now I have
another one.
So that means this character
gets selected.
And then I go up to here,
OK, and then up to here.
And now I go diagonally again,
which means that this character
is selected.
And I go to here,
and then I go here.
And then, I go up here and this
character is selected.
So here is my longest common
subsequence.
And this was just one path
back.
I could have gone a path like
this and gotten a different
longest common subsequence.
OK, so that simplification of
just saying, look,
let me just run backwards and
figure it out,
that's actually pretty good
because it means that by just
calculating the value,
then figuring out these back
pointers to let me reconstruct
it is a fairly simple process.
OK, if I had to think about
that to begin with,
it would have been a much
bigger mess.
OK, so the space,
I just mentioned,
was order MN because we still
need the table.
So, you can actually do the min
of m and n.
OK, to get to your question,
how do you do the min of m and
n?
Diagonal stripes won't give you
min of m and n.
That'll give you the sum of m
and n.
So, going in stripes,
maybe I'm not quite sure I know
what you mean.
So, you're saying,
so what's the order I would do
here?
So, I would start.
I would do this one first.
Then which one would I do?
This one and this one?
And then, this one,
this one, this one,
like this?
That's a perfectly good order.
OK, and so you're saying,
then, so I'm keeping the
diagonal there all the time.
So, you're saying the length of
the diagonal is the min of m and
n?
I think that's right.
OK, there is another way you
can do it that's a little bit
more straightforward,
which is you compare m to n.
Whichever is smaller,
well, first of all,
let's just do this existing
algorithm.
If I just simply did row by
row, I don't need more than a
previous row.
OK, I just need one row at a
time.
So, I can go ahead and compute
just one row because once I
computed the succeeding row,
the first row is unimportant.
And in fact,
I don't even need the whole
row.
All I need is just the current
row that I'm on,
plus one or two elements of the
previous row,
plus the end of the previous
row.
So, I use a prefix of this row,
and an extra two elements,
and the suffix of this row.
So, it's actually,
you can do it with one row,
plus order one element.
And then, I could do it either
running vertically or running
horizontally,
whichever one gives me the
smaller space.
OK, and it might be that your
diagonal trick would work there
too.
I'd have to think about that.
Yeah?
Ooh, that's a good question.
So, you can do the calculation
of the length,
and run row plus order one
elements.
OK, and our exercise,
and this is a hard exercise,
OK, so that a good one to do is
to do small space and allow you
to reconstruct the LCS because
the nave way that we were just
doing it, it's not clear how you
would go backwards from that
because you've lost the
information.
OK, so this is actually a very
interesting and tricky problem.
And, it turns out it succumbs
of all things to divide and
conquer, OK, rather than some
more straightforward tabular
thing.
OK: so very good practice,
for example,
for the upcoming take home
quiz, OK, which is all design
and cleverness type quiz.
OK, so this is a good one for
people to take on.
So, this is basically the
tabular method that's called
dynamic programming.
OK, memo-ization is not dynamic
programming, even though it's
related.
It's memo-ization.
And, we're going to see a whole
bunch of other problems that
succumb to dynamic programming
approaches.
It's a very cool method,
and on the homework,
so let me just mention the
homework again.
On the homework,
we're going to look at a
problem called the edit distance
problem.
Edit distance is you are given
two strings.
And you can imagine that you're
typing in a keyboard with one of
the strings there.
And what you have to do is by
doing inserts,
and deletes,
and replaces,
and moving the cursor around,
you've got to transform one
string to the next.
And, each of those operations
has a cost.
And your job is to minimize the
cost of transforming the one
string into the other.
This actually turns out also to
be useful for computational
biology applications.
And, in fact,
there have been editors,
screen editors,
text editors,
that implement algorithms of
this nature in order to minimize
the number of characters that
have to be sent as IO in and out
of the system.
So, the warning is,
you better get going on your
programming on problem one on
the homework today if at all
possible because whenever I
assign programming,
since we don't do that as sort
of a routine thing,
I'm just concerned for some
people that there will not be
able to get things like the
input and output to work,
and so forth.
We have example problems,
and such, on the website.
And we also have,
you can write it in any
language you want,
including Matlab,
Python, whatever your favorite,
the solutions will be written
in Java and Python.
OK, so the fastest solutions
are likely to be written in c.
OK, you can also do it in
assembly language if you care
to.
You laugh.
I used to be in assembly
language programmer back in the
days of yore.
OK, so I do encourage people to
get started on this because let
me mention, the other thing is
that this particular problem on
this problem set is an
absolutely mandatory problem.
OK, all the problems are
mandatory, but as you know you
can skip them and it doesn't
hurt you too much if you only
skip one or two.
This one, you skip,
hurts big time:
one letter grade.
It must be done.